um today we have our speaker is Fabio
he's the VP of engineering at opor
leading the Feature Feature store
development team and know the master's
degree in out Computing and services
with the focus on data intensive
applications and this talk does not need
power knowledge and mainly this Workshop
Feld to building ml systems to predict
air quality yeah this will be until 250
and I guess the last 10 minutes will be
Q&A depending on how long you
want oops okay actually there's an
update uh we doing loan approval not a
quality but it's the same
concept same same same
ideas um yeah welcome everybody thank
you thank you for
joining maybe I don't know we see um
yeah so I'm I'm Fabio um I Le the
engineering team at OB and OB is.
company um we spent the last couple of
years building upss um and the reason we
do that is some some the reason we
beated them today in our Workshop um the
workshop is actually split into two
different
[Music]
um Can people hear me if I speak
just
[Music]
okay hope it's going to be
fine we just holding yeah
that's that's okay yeah so I'm saying um
there are two different uh uh section of
this of the workshop I'm going to give
you a little bit of introductions on um
how we think about machine systems what
we think machine learning systems are um
and how uh you can use like some the
components that you buil in offs to um
to build them and then um the next
section is a little bit more andon um we
have a bunch of tutorials that that we
can go through um and look at it and and
so build a very simple um machine
Learning System to uh predict whether or
not um a loan should be approved uh
depending on on on the user requesting
it right um so the reason for this
Workshop to be essentially it's um it's
that um if you if you're trying to be a
scientist what you often do is you often
do like let's say Caro challenges and
everybody has done them I've done them
myself as well um but that's that's not
the end game that's not what we believe
the end game is the end game is to be
able to build um systems that leverage
models and build applications that
leverage models um either in production
for like you know company use cases and
stuff uh but also for like you know site
projects and so on right um there are
different levels of machine learning
machine Learning Systems um or like
generally speaking um applications that
leverage um uh machine learning um we
still from the bottom um the bottom is
what we call Laptop ml this is more like
classical like C challenge where
essentially you get a CSP f um you do
some training um you do some predictions
and a few go um that's not we consider a
machine Learning System um a machine
Learning System to be considered like
that uh it's a system where new data
continuously arve to to to to your uh to
your model whether to uh make new
predictions and you can do that either
in real time um so for instance stuff
like um the commodation system set
social networks um gets you know uh
makes you predictions based on your um
most recent activities but also you can
do that in BS right so um you know OBS
is originally from Sweden um Sweden is
also the almost Spotify and one of the
most like um known features they have no
capability they have in spify spify
weekly where every week they get
basically um they recommend for every
user um a bunch of like a bunch of um
songs that they might be interested on
right so So today we're going to be
focusing on the first stop two uh we're
going to be looking at um how to build
um operational machine Learning Systems
uh in Python um leveraging obor and and
lever some of the capabilities that that
we built in obor um right now right so
the second motivation for this stock to
be is that it's not trivia to build this
type of machine Learning Systems um and
often times um people start like
especially if you work in in a company
in a in a in maybe in a m Enterprise so
on what you often end up doing is that
okay I have to build models and you
start looking at what's my like machine
learning um uh infrastructure let say um
setup right and you end up with
something like this on the right side
that's the most like a SED paper in the
m space um and the reason you end up in
that situation actually two reasons the
first one is that um people think about
mlops in terms of like components not in
terms of processes and so then you know
you need need to have all the boxes
checked out to be able to actually start
start building stuff um and the second
one is that and ultimately and the
reason why we spend time building UPS is
um ultimately putting models in
production is is a data challenge right
a lot of the arrows going around the
essentially is like feeding data to
different components um and you know
that's that's that's quite chotic right
and especially if you are building a
side project especially if you're
building like a small project a small
prototype um there's a lot of complexity
there that you that we don't think that
we think we don't have to deal with it
essentially right so how do you how do
we think that you should actually build
this these type of systems right um if
you go back um we think that you should
look at in terms of like data flow
essentially how does data move through
your model how is data used across
training your model um you know making
predictions and so on right so if you go
back to the original uh statement
basically saying okay we we build like a
like a we we we partip to a c challenge
right we get a bunch of CSP files um we
do some training um and then we do some
prediction essentially um that's what we
Define uh like the monolitic machinary
pipel because essentially there's no
separation of the different stages it's
basically just one potentially one
gigantic python script essentially right
but if you look within that specific
python script what you actually find is
that there are three um separate stages
let's say you can you can identify right
um you can have a like a feature
pipeline which is basically the one
actually Computing the features um you
take the features from the feature
Pipeline and then you actually build up
the model build theual model you know
like you know um cular and so on um and
ultimately you're making predictions
right you're need making predictions in
in bats right so you basically take some
more data from either same CSV file or
some other data sources and you make
predictions or in more complex scenarios
um you have you know um an end point
that's basically being called where your
model is a predictions and that that's
basically real time real time
predictions um one thing that one think
that you need to do um if you actually
start Bing discount system this is what
we I would say recommend um when people
want to build machine Learning System is
that um these are independent components
um we can look a little bit later in
like how you build them um but the the
underline the underline benefit of this
is that a
um you can have like different languages
and different Frameworks to build each
and every stage of the pipeline and then
you can also have different team members
doing that right you can have a team
member responsible for creating the
features um or t Team responsible to
create the features t Team responsible
for building models and entire team
responsible for model in production um
what we actually uh what we actually
think you should do as well is um that's
where kind of OBS come to the picture
you need a way to uh communicate
um for the different pipelines to
basically exchange information exchange
features um exchange the actual model
weights and so on right so that's where
OBS uh we see OB fitting into this
architecture um essentially again
feature pipeline um so op provides the
API we see in a second um and the UI um
for um let's say feature pip to be able
to register features for training PIP
plan to be able to retrieve those
features and then the INF PIP plan to be
able to um retri the features more
features data in either real time or BS
to be able to make uh
predictions now um the specific project
we're going to be looking at is as I
said it's a it's a it's a project to
determine whether or not um um um a loan
should be approved um a loan application
should be approved um but before get
into the model itself uh we want to
start thinking about um we want to start
thinking about the different stages as
we explained and and we want to start
thinking about what we need from each
and every stage right um so the left
side we start from the left side is data
management right let me just this is
more like okay where is the underline
data coming from right this uh you have
different options uh most likely if
you're working in a in a company um your
data comes from most likely different
sources um you have data coming from
either data L like S3 for instance or
you might have data like snowlake uh you
might have um streaming data you might
have a graph database um so this is
basically all data sources you need um
to be able to to kind of uh build the
features you need to betic trainer model
so the the second step is said what the
feature pipeline which is basically um
you know how to build the actual
features um the feature pipel is
responsible as you said just take the um
under data from the external data
sources create the features and register
them with the feature store um
potentially you can also use it to um
manage the labels we see that there
options in up API to be able to
externally um obviously you know um how
and where your your model are trained um
which framework you going to be using um
and where specifically you train the
model you need to use which kind of op
you need to be able to the model and
finally um the inference pipeline um is
all about how you make predictions right
um do you actually have all the data in
the fure store can some of data might
might might only be known when um when a
request is sent in for a model to
predict um and also um that's that's a
prediction need to happen in real time
what kind of SAS do we have uh to be
able to return a prediction and you know
or this can be for instance um can be
for instance a let's say a b pred and
finally you know how how is the how are
the prodiction consume um in our example
we're going to build like a like a t
radio UI um to show the predictions but
this might be another service or may be
another user consuming consuming those
predictions and there are some of the
options that we have available um is
said we're going to go a little bit
deeper into into details later
on okay so um before I I I jump into the
next section um and look at the
different stages of those pipelines in a
practical example um you can follow
along um there are two two uh links you
actually need okay this is now bit
problem um you can actually you can
actually uh there are two actually links
you need to uh need to to be able to
follow the tutorial the first one is
upop um that's our service deployment
it's there it's free for everybody to
join um there is no need for registering
credit card or payment in general um is
there um you're going to get access to
it even after the uh tutorial is is is
done um you can use it to build you know
site projects and you know experiment
with things um and and it's there um the
second one is um our tutorial repository
so it's dat.com
blocks Ops tutorials um here you can
find a bunch of different tutorials let
me just one
second
so here you can find a bunch of
different tutorials that we have
available um they all follow the same PN
um for this specific one uh we're going
to be looking at the Lo loan approval
process um and we're going to be looking
at different the different notebooks
what they're doing what kind of um what
kind of uh abstraction they're using OBS
and so on um but you can also
oops you can also um you can also look
at the the other VFS on example in
streaming um we have some example
streaming in in uh in in Python using a
tool called BX we have some example in
in spark Flink and and so on um yeah
today we're going to be focusing on on
python so this is the only thing only
the things you need uh to to get to get
running um if you have any problem with
like set up an accounts or anything like
this uh there is a there's a a person in
the back with the same t-shirt like as
mine um yeah feel free to raise your
hand and then it's going to come and
help you out essentially or we can you
know you can stop me after the talk and
it's not going to be a
problem okay so um what's the what's the
specific example about right so um this
specific example is as we said um let me
actually jump here um this specific
example is basically looking at um data
coming from a platform called Ling Club
um Ling Club is a peer-to-peer platform
U that where basically people can you
know lend one into each other um and and
the nice thing about them is that they
make the data available um open source
essentially right so you can basically
download the data periodically I think
it's daady um they basically make
available those some CSV file with uh
information about the loan applications
and some information about the uses and
so on right so in this example um the
ultimate goal is to um predict whether
or not a given Lo should be approved or
not right um there's a bunch of
different use cases you can apply a year
for instance you can potentially build a
model to prict what's your exposure in
ter in terms of risk as a as a lender or
um as a borrower or as a platform um and
so this specific one we going be looking
at um whether or not a loans should be
approved um the first thing if if you
remember the if you remember this slide
uh that we were looking at before uh to
like identify different stages first one
obviously is to identify the data
sources um as I said earlier um the um
the landing Cloud platform releases um
two um main uh CSP files um I think it's
da as he said um one is the um CSV file
and the other one is the applicant CSV
file now the way we manage um data
sources the way we manage feature
pipeline is actually by creating more
upour we Define as feature groups so
feature groups are an obstruction that
we have in OBS um they represent a set
of features that are referring to a
specific um to a specific key right so
in this this Cas in this case can be um
like the the loan ID you will seen in
the next slide is going to be the the
applicant ID um it could be user profile
ID or intern essentially right so unique
identifier um what you can see in the
second column um is something called
event time um the event time is really
important when you're doing uh when
you're doing machine running with
transactional data so as data changes
over time and most most use Cas actually
do that
right um as dat changes over time um you
don't want to you don't want to update
the existing roles you want to actually
create new roles and the reason you want
to do that is U to be able to track
history and to be able to um correctly
join and you see it in a second whether
that means um different features um so
that um there is no data Le so you're
not Jo feature values from today with
the feature value of tomorrow for
instance so that's what the event time
is used for it's that available and
we're going to be using it in OB in a
second um after that we have a bunch of
different features these are a couple of
different like features about the loans
so the interest rate uh the purpose of
the loan um the loan amount and finally
we have the the loan status right the
loan status is what's going to be our
lab as I said earlier um you can use
opss to store also the labels themselves
um and we have the API to be able to
manage those um you don't have to um
they they the labels can come as a as an
external data source when you're your
model ens right so that's makes it a
little bit more easy to build more
complex um pipel and so
on um the next as you said it's it's the
applicants um same same idea we have the
ID as First Column of the applicant ID
uh we have um the another Lu time uh
column uh for the specific values of the
applicant feature group and then we have
a bunch of different um a bunch of
different features um that are specific
to the to the
applicant
now uh one of thing I was mentioning
earlier is the the the the value of the
um the value of the event time itself
right so in this specific case right we
have like user applying to diff to loans
and potentially multiple times um
throughout the the data set and between
like loan applications the user let's
say the user annual income might
actually change right so um it can
happen for instance that like maybe a
couple of years ago my income was really
low and I couldn't I couldn't basically
qualify for a specific loan but then my
income increased and so then I I
actually can qualify now right so if you
were to join the features from the loan
applications um maybe a couple of years
ago with my status today that would be
data leakage right that would be not a
valid actually dat set right so um what
we actually want to do is we want to
make sure that when we joining feature
groups together uh when we joining
features coming from different sources
together um we are joining that in um
point it that correct way right and this
is even more important um if you're
dealing with more Dynamic data sources
right so if you're dealing for instance
with um you know streaming data or we
dealing with like um joining streaming
data with for instance you know slow
moving data from data warehouse um
that's something that you you want you
want to take into consideration um we
see later in a second that actually you
don't have to kind of remember this the
platform is going to take care of for
you um okay so um let's let's jump into
the code and start looking at it a
little bit um we have um three notebooks
um and like actually the like a like a
um gradi UI um the two notebooks are the
feature pipeline um and then we also
have the training Pipeline and then the
last notebook is a batch inference and
then the application is actually a real
time inference application
essentially so if we first first start
looking at the first one um the first
one is um the the feature PIP plan right
here it's important to let's say
highlight what a fure pipel is and what
it isn't right so one of the things that
we we generally recommend when you build
future pipel oook is not to do um
encoding oranization of the featur so
that's usually like really like like I
would say um really frequent operation
that you do when you train U models um
the reason we ask you not to do that if
when you in your feature pip when your
Computing features
is that it really um um makes it hard
for you to reuse featur across different
models right and the reason for that is
for instance you might have different
models that looking at different subset
of the data and then obviously
normalization will apply on the entire
on entire data set and then make that
for instance the feature would have to
be used only for a specific model right
um so we see in a second um you can
actually postpone the normalization
process um all the way into the uh into
the training Pipeline and INF Pipeline
and so the features are mostly computed
out of let's say aggregations um maybe
you're Ling some features maybe you're
joining features from multiple um data
sources um maybe you're doing some
embedding and stuff like this right so
all of this um happen in the future
pipel one thing that you will not see in
the future pipel um that we have in our
example is the normalization we actually
see it later on in in in the in the
training notebook
Cen now how do you write feature
pipelines well in this specific example
we're going to be looking at pandas um
obook has pretty much flexible um uh set
of ecosystem that can plugs in um if if
you're doing streaming applications
that's where like for instance stuff
like piceart um Flink and beam can
actually help you um there's a tool
called bbox that does some of the
streaming application in P python so you
can actually use that one to um handle
like streaming data um you might
actually work in a company that has a
data weh somewhere and so that that
point you might be actually looking at
you know just using data data from data
warehouse to be able to actually build
uh build those
features now let's let's have a look at
let's have a look at the code um and
let's have a look at this one can people
see can people in the back see somewhat
perfect amazing um yeah so there's
actually like a zero notebook um the
zero notebook is actually goes through a
little bit more in detail about the data
set um what the different fields mean
and and and you know what the label mean
and so on um for that specific example
you can just go through um by yourself
um and then let's have a look at the
actual the actual code right so the
first thing you see is that we actually
retrieving the data uh from an htpn
Point um yeah we ring the data for a
specific date um and we see that in a
second why this is important um this is
the data set itself and we do the same
for the uh for the applicants uh for the
applicants CSP file well this is
actually a 4K file but
anyway out of this we actually have two
data frames um here we basically are
Computing as we said two different
feature groups um the applicant feure
groups and the um and the loan feure
groups um in OBX you don't have to um
like everything in a single feature
pipel right you can have multiple
feature pipel obviously um here in a
single notebook and so in a single
pipeline essentially um just because for
convenience essentially just so it's
easier to to kind of work around right
so one thing I one thing I want to
mention as well is the way we suggest
people to organize feature engineering
right so this is a Notebook based
development um often times when it comes
to let's say U deploying models of
production one of the critical aspect um
that you want to ensure is that data can
in and it's always computed with the
same part
um and the same met aggregations and so
on and there are no breaking changes
between different RS of your
application um we seen a second how we
manage version in obor um but one other
thing you want to do is also make sure
that you can actually um a manage a code
base that produces those features and
also B you need test those uh feat
Transformations the way we actually do
that in OBS it's actually not
necessarily an upso thing but it's
actually a best practice that you can
actually Implement anywhere um it's
actually to write those features as
feature functions and actually store
them not in Notebook itself but actually
in a separate file so that way you can
actually see here if I look at my uh the
features the feature functions for my my
Appliance fe grop uh what you can
actually see is that you you have like
for each individual feature you have um
add different function right and then
you can actually unit test these
functions right these are pretty simple
um but potentially you can have more
business logic here that you want a unit
test uh to make sure that that like if
someone pushes a new change um the same
uh the same results are are are
basically produced and so there are no I
say breaking changes essentially and
what actually happens in pandas you can
actually pretty do pretty easily do
something like data from that apply and
then you basically apply this specific
um this specific feature function uh to
the specific uh column or multiple
columns to produce your feature right
and you do that for basically a bunch of
them um you can go through um we been
doing Al some cleaning dropping some of
the some of the columns in the original
data frames that uh we don't care
about and ultimately what's going to
happen is you end up with a data frame
actually we end up with like two data
frames one for the let's skip this part
for a second uh one for the um one for
the applicants and one for the loans and
what you actually do um the the the
entire um process of ring your data
frame with UPS works is basically this
this basically these two cells right so
if you take for instance the um the the
loan Fe group the first thing you do is
basically Define what we call a feature
group so a collection of features that
are available for um for different uh uh
for different models to use right for
different version of the model to use
for different use cases and so on um and
here they basically Define just the
features that that you have in your data
frame right so you're basically defining
the name of your feature group the
version and come back on the version in
second um you can have description both
at the feature group level but also the
feature level um you can basically do
okay I want I want this use case to be
available online for Real Time
applications that's where for instance
the online enable comes into the picture
so here we're about basically asking OBS
when we write the data frame to also
make sure data frame gets written in the
online feature store for Real Time
retrieval and then we have um the
primary key which is going to be useful
later on when we going to join features
together and the event time we discussed
it earlier um to be able to say this
column is my my day time um and also
just going to use this column to do what
we talked about earlier um the point
correct joint um between different
feature groups right and then ultimately
what you actually end up doing um you
can actually see here is basically say
Lo long feature group insert and you
basically provide the data frame that
you want to write into the into the
feature store
I really run this one as you can see and
so how does that look in UPS right um so
if you look at obso um this is my uh
this is my setup of the of the um
service deployment I have a bunch of
different feature groups that I have
created um earlier on and you can
actually see if you look at the loans
feature group this is what um I just
created with the code right this is how
how it looks um we have all the features
that are part of these feature groups
these are automatically detected by the
data frame itself so these are the
columns that you actually have in data
frame the types um you can actually side
add description so to make it
searchable um one of the other things
that we uh we we just skipped earlier on
was the integration with Great
Expectations right so if you are
familiar with expectation great
expectation is a very popular library to
do data validation and there are
actually two aspect in obso to uh
monitor the data right because here what
basically happens if you are running
this thing in a company what's going to
happen is that you will have a team
writing the features and then someone
else will need to trust these features
and these feature values to be able to
build them model right so expectations
are a way for you to kind of establish
what the community calls like data
contracts um to be able to say okay this
is what my data looks like right so in
OB you can basically say okay you can
basically install the great expectation
library and basically say okay I expect
my interest rate to be between these two
numbers now I hope you're not going to
get a loan for like 2,000% interest rate
but anyway um ultimately that's what
that's what the expectations um are
going to inforce so if you write
something that is below 2% minus 2% or
above 2,000% then um we uh we have two
options right the first option is
basically to say I'm going to trigger an
alert and I'm going to notify someone
okay you can actually do it from either
from API but you can do it from the UI
this is how it's configure right now
right basically say um notify someone
that like something went wrong but keep
writing anyway right this is actually
what happens the expectation failed um
and then wejust it anyway um the other
aspect you can actually do you can
actually set it in strict mode so if
there is an expectation that fails then
at that point do not write anything and
trigger an alert right so that's more
for production use cases where you want
to make sure actually data under data is
actually um there is another
functionality that it's it's it's sort
of in in the making OBS um at the moment
which is actually more um in the real of
like data monitoring so looking at how
these loans feature data changes over
time and making sure that like if for
instance certain statistic um of certain
features um diverge from what you train
your model on then you get an alert um
you can potentially rer your model the
site you R your
model so this is actually um this is
actually what we um what we created so
far um we have created two feature
groups um and we basically just register
we doing the exact same thing for the
applicants we just Chang the um the
primary key and the event time and then
we basically um we basically again call
the insert method for the data frame um
here we are doing um the description
tagging so we we are we basically have a
dictionary without description and the
specific column um the specific feature
that we care about and then we call the
API to be able to type that specific
column uh with that specific description
right so this is basically just just
some metadata uh operation to be able to
populate the descriptions so that's
essentially the feature pipeline that I
have here um one other thing I want to I
want to talk about um addition to to
what we just said about the fure
pipeline okay we talk about the um you
know making feature functions like like
um the small and to like to a specific
feature so that you can you need test
them this is what I want to talk about I
want to talk about like how do we
orchestrate this thing right obviously
the feat pipe one of the things one
thing that distinguish like let's say a
simple model from an ml system is that
new data comes in every time every day
every hour like in real time right so if
you're doing uh if you're building a
machine system one thing you need to
need to worry about is um obviously
orchestration of the PIP right so here
you kind of have two options right you
can um you can either do like time B
scheduling and OB as support for it you
can basically say run this job every
let's say every day every hour or
something um the problem with time based
scheduling is that um you your pipeline
might have like Upstream dependencies
right you might have a dependency from
some external let's say um external uh
you know process that basically takes
data from a database and D the data
warehouse for your pip just read it and
and create the features um so if that
Upstream pipeline fails then and you're
doing 10 based scheduling your pipel is
going to run anyway right it doesn't
have any knowledge about okay the PIP
has F right and so this is where um
there are a bunch more like complex
orchestration tools like airflow um and
and du set for instance that allow you
to like you know specify those pipeline
in a much more more um in a much more
complex way but also um with much more
control over dependencies between
different steps and so
on um we talk about Great Expectations
and integration with
obss and okay so now now now we going to
the the the actual training pipeline
right so we have created L features and
they are available in the feature store
we have a pipeline in place that runs
every every day um and update those
those values append new value a new
values into it um and so now we want to
train we want to train our model so when
it comes to train our model um the the
the idea behind a feature store is that
you have um tons of features there and
you obviously not necessarily need all
of them right one of the things you
would actually see I want to show you
now um is that if I look for instance at
the statistics of the features and I
look at the loan itself you can see that
for instance the installment and don't
amount are basically with each other
right um so maybe I don't want to
include them both into into the same
into the same train data set because I
mean they don't provide necessarily
value having both of them there um so
what you're actually do um there are
different stages that you can do um to
actually select the features right
whether or not the feature is useful in
the first place whether or not is
redundant like like we were looking at
just now um whether there is no point on
having it because it has no predicted
power into into that specific problem
that we are looking at um in some cases
especially if you're working with like
in financial institutions or like
medical institutions you might have a
more strict approach in terms of like
personal personal identify information
um so you might have actually features
that you can actually canot use um in in
your model and then you know the ma
features that you would like to have but
you can't um I mean they too expensive
to Compu for some reason right so what
you're actually doing is that you
basically you're basically going going
around like with the shopping cart and
basically selecting the features that
you you car you want to include into
your specific model and you can do that
using the API and we s in a second and
what we actually end up creating is we
end up creating what we call a feature
view right a feature view is basically
like a metadata object that basically
says this specific model needs these
specific features from the two different
for from my feature groups in this case
from the two of them and the way it can
be much more more more than more than
two um the important aspect is one of
those feature groups is actually what we
call a label feature group right so
that's where the label kind of comes
from for my prediction problem um and
then we basically attaching um to the
label all the all the features that we
can um that that we want to include in
my TR data
set now the feature view is a is a
powerful obstruction um not only because
allows us to basically create a
different subset of features to include
in my specific model um by analysis do a
bunch of different things right one
thing obviously said selection feat the
selection of feat features um the other
aspect is um identifying which one which
of the features is going to be my label
right this is going to be useful later
on in the inference pipeline because
we're going to use the same feature view
object to do inference um to maintain
consistency um and so in that specific
case um the loan the label is not going
to be available right the loan St is not
going to be available because that's
what we're trying to predict so here we
basically telling the feuture view this
specific colum is only is only going to
be available at training time but not at
INF time you can apply filters um so um
fature groups as we said are let's say
free agent features right they are
available for everybody to use and to
build different use cases to build
different models and so ultimately what
happens is that you can basically say I
have let's say all my customer globally
on um all my applicants toally on the on
the applicant feature group and then I
want to say okay this specific model um
applies for only the US customers or
only the European customers or this case
this model apply only for um loan
operation loan request that apply for
for mortgage and then the last part is
what we were talking about earlier which
is basically say now that I I I I select
the features I want to include I filter
them to the subset of features I feature
data actually want to use in my data set
now I can actually apply Transformations
right now I can actually do the
normalization I can actually do um the
say one coding and and situation like
this right so this will allow me to
basically build for instance another
feature view with a different filter on
the same feature groups but with
different um um yeah with different with
different with different filters and
this is what we call U model dependent
Transformations because they are
dependent on the specific model and this
case they depend on specific feature
view which is going to be used by a
specific
model um feature view is
actually
oops okay view um as you said we talking
I looked a little bit earlier has two
different apis um as an API for um
retrieving train data and as an API for
retrieving iners data right and one of
the problem you you you face um when you
when when it's time to build say um
Machining systems is especially if you
are in a large company what basically
happens is that the um the people
working on on the on the modeling side
of things are not the same people that
actually work on the machine learning
operation side of things right so you
need to keep you need to enforce a
consistency between um what what you
have in your train asset the type of
features you have in your train asset
and the type of features you have in
your in data you use for inference right
and the feature view does that right the
feature view will um provide the the
guarantees that data is the same same
features are the same same
transformation are been applied the same
FS have been applied and so on right so
let's have a look at let's have a look a
little bit at the code um that we have
here so if you are following along
that's the U the second uh notebook that
we have um what you can see here is as
always we we log in and I didn't show
you earlier this is how you take any
python uh process and you log in into
your own um obso um account be basically
prompt to uh generate an AP is click on
the link you opens the page on on OBS
the and it's going to um give you back a
like a key you can use um so if you want
to start creating a feat view um the
first thing you do is create what we
call a quy object um a quy object is U
again a metadata operation metadata
object it doesn't store any data itself
it's not creating rep because of data
itself um and the way you create the
actual uh the actual quity is by using
um the python AP and here if you're
familiar with the way um let's say
you're merging data frames together in
in pandas that's exactly what what we're
trying to do here essentially right so
here we basically say okay from the
loans feature
group um select all my features except
these two uh we don't want to include
the primary keys in my the asset and we
don't want to my uh we don't want to
include the event time in the data set
um so we want to exclude them and join
them together with every features from
the applicant feature group uh except
the primary key and the date time that
we that we have defined areer again here
we not specifying any specific um
joining key um it's again it's the same
as as you do in pandas if you do that
what up is going to do is going to be
looking at um the different primary keys
of different feature groups and it's
going to join on the um largest matching
subset of keys that these two F groups
have in common right in this case um
both the uh loan um feature group and
the second both the loan feature group
and the applicant feature group as a
primary key the ID and so what what the
API is going to look like are they going
to what the API is going to do is
actually going to they're going to join
on the ID as a as a joining team um what
the API also is going to do
is going to create a point time correct
join um we were looked at earlier um
this is a generally speaking a complex
way to write U because you have to align
events at at different rates um coming
from different future groups potentially
here you can have potentially maybe five
six 10 feature groups um and so you have
to align um the loan applications that
you have in the feature Group which is
your what we call a label feature group
with all the events from the other
feature groups essentially right um
and what basically happens is that you
basically get back um an object you can
actually have a quick look at the data
itself and I looks like so here you
basically just have all the um all the
um all the features that are going to be
included in your 20 asset and then you
basically register that with OBS right
you basically saying um I'm going to
create a feature view object with that
specific name that specific version um
loan status as we said earlier um is
going to be my
TB and and that's it basically what
we're going to see is that we actually
going to see in the feature view itself
uh you can actually see I have a loan
approval feature view here where you can
basically see all the features have been
applied and where they're coming from
you can actually see it in a diagram
itself um and you can actually do a
bunch of different things with the
feature view right so we said earlier
feature views are what's what are used
for either create ret but also to create
inference data right so if you look at
for instance um in this specific example
what we actually doing is we want to
train a model and here we're basically
saying give me back a data frame
actually give back four data frames uh
which are split in test test and TR
split and the test split should be 20%
this we are doing here we doing like a
like a random test uh ROM split if
you're dealing with let's say time time
CS data you can also do um you know you
can actually set let's say x amount of
time to to be included in my train data
set um and you know a couple of other
weeks a couple of months to be included
in my in my in my test data set right so
you can actually specify the dates
beginning and end for different for
different splits and again um the API
know which one is going to be your label
and so you're basically going to get
back um you're going to get back let me
see if I can actually you find this
one time is something fine
yeah which
one so in in the meantime should not
take long
um in the meantime what I want to talk
about is talk about the the um the
transformation functions right there are
two strategy you can actually use here
um here using um second learn um
transformation like secondar pipes and
use that to actually do Transformations
um you can apply that um you can apply
that um on your data coming in it's
nothing OB specific um and you can
register that that the pipelines um as
part of your model with your model
registry um there is another thing you
can actually do in op you can actually
specify it here uh you can bu specify
dictionary and use the alation functions
um
they are a little bit more they are a
little bit more limited in term cap
capabilities the transformation function
coming from up and so depending on what
you're doing you might get away with
that or you might have to kind of fall
back on the um kind of fall back on the
uh on the um secondy pipelines
essentially so yes what we talking
earlier we were just doing a bunch of
like um uh encoding on the actual
features before before actually uh
providing it to the to the actual model
and then again this is just a simple
model training operation and what we
actually going to be doing is you're
going to save that um in the OBS mod
register so OBS itself has a m register
component that you can use um some
people use like stuff like mlow um and
Other M registry uh you can save it on
you know um yeah a bunch of other uh
tools out there here we just save it
nwor so that we can basically track the
lineage end to end uh from the feature
groups to the to the model and
predictions and so
on uh let me see if this one
okay um okay so let me have a look back
here we created the feature view um we
have look at we cre set we actually
train the model um one thing I wanted to
mention earlier as well is that um
because we have a separation of what a
feature group what a feature group is
and what a feature view is um and we
said earlier that new data can seeing
every every day or every every hour or
depending on on the on the frequency um
well basically you you you can basically
see is that for instance um you can
actually get new data coming in and use
the new data to you to do inference
right but then you know a month from now
you can decide to retrain your model
right and so what you basically have to
do if you go back to let's say um
here see this one uh what you can
basically see is basically basically get
a new train data set right and this
basically is going to generate a new
train data set including all the new
data that has arrived in the meantime so
this is going to be let's say trb2 and
trb3 and so on so forth um the nice
aspect of the feature views uh is that
um you don't have to um let's say uh you
don't have to remember uh which features
are includeed right you can just
basically ask each of you uh okay give
me back a new set of data to train my
model and then specific model um doesn't
need to change you don't you don't risk
you don't get into the risk of to say um
you know breaking the texure of the
model breaking the input and so on right
so um and yeah this is this is what I
was saying earlier you basically get as
as you get new R coming in um you get
new TR being generated and then finally
um you know you can actually use the B
data and then ultimately when you get
the label you can actually use it for um
for train new model new ver of the
models um you look at this one the code
um said how to create specific pipelines
um in specific seg pipeline for
Transformations we look at out you can
actually register and create the model
for it um you can store some of the
metrics in it and you can store the
input of your model um both in terms of
like train the set but you can also
store it as a um this case as as as a
you know as as as type and and and
values you are
expecting um and you can also store so
this is up is to store an example of the
input right so you can actually test the
UI you can have a quick example to
actually test
it now we have train our model um we
have new data coming in every day um and
so we want to make sure that every day
we also are making new inference right
so here we have um two different use
cases right we have a use case where
we're looking at for instance um uh
bence so we're basically looking at you
know all the applications that came in
yesterday we're going to train we're
going to we're going to make a predic on
them or we're going to be looking at um
we're going to be looking at more real
time application where let's say um a
users on a website um and is making an
application and we want to determine
immediately whether or not that
application should be accepted or not
right
so um let me actually have a look at the
code um just one second so so there are
two different aspect you said earlier um
the first one is the um the the number
three
notebooks so this is more uh the best
use case um so again here we are
retrieving this specific feature view
object that we want to we want to use
for our specific model we're going to
talk in a second about the version that
we have there but essentially you can
basically do the following you can do
you can call this um B data get B data
method and and you providing basically
the start time and the end time based on
the event time the futs right so you
basically say give me back all the loan
applications that we have received in
the last you know 24 hours or whatever
the St time and the end time is
basically right so again here we don't
have to specify which features we want
to include we don't have to specify
which Transformations we want to include
everything is is encoded into the uh
stor into the uh feature view object and
you know we just basically get back a
data frame and actually call this dat
frame you can basically get back and
then you can basically call um model the
predict on that one uh to be able to um
you know make predictions on whether or
not a specific loan should be should be
granted or not right so this is
basically um the previous the most
simple example in terms of b um but we
also have an example in real time for
instance so for instance here we have
let me actually yeah okay so here we
have basically the same example but
instead of basically retrieving um every
new request sorry every every day
basically retrieving the uh the last 24
hours of data we are basically having a
UI that the user can actually use let me
just anounce a second so we can
[Music]
see
second in the
meantime um we are using the same Fe
object um this is the line that we're
looking at we basically re that object
um again the same information we don't
have to remember what kind of features
are we are included from where they
coming from and so on how they are
computed and so on um what we actually
be doing is we call this different
method right now instead of calling the
get data we call this get feature Vector
method right the get feature Vector
method um is that different because it
actually goes to what we call the online
feature store right so if you remember
all the way at the beginning when we
were creating the features we said I
want to I want off to store these
features on the uh on the online feature
store and so they are available for low
lat retrial right um the difference the
difference here is that when you're
retrieving data from the man store you
cannot ask for a Time range you have to
ask for a specific ID right you have to
ask for in this case a specific user ID
U that we want to include into um they
want I use to to to be able to make a
prediction on essentially and actually
let me see if this one has it yes
second
Yeah so basically imagine this but in a
more like you know professional way um
you can basically say okay I'm I'm on
the website of my bank and I want to
apply for a loan um these are the things
that I I I want they they ask me um and
what basically happen when I click
submit is the following right so couple
of things the first one is we said that
they're going to looking at the get
feature vector and some of the features
though they are not available um in the
feature store right so for instance I
ask for a specific loan for a specific
reason right in this case the own
Improvement um obviously it's not going
to be available in F store right um
because I just ask for it um in that
specific case you get feature Vector
method as a way for you to basically say
um ask the feature the feature view to
basically um inject some of the barriers
um and ignore whatever is coming from
the uh from the online feature store you
most likely get nothing back from the
online feature store because again it's
all part of the same entity that doesn't
exist yet there yet you don't have a Lo
application there in your feature store
yet you will have it maybe tomorrow um
but in this case you can actually just
provide these values um yourself and if
you have applied transformation function
on this specific so if you have
normalized for instance the in rate or
something like this um the feature view
object is going to actually do that for
you right um so you just have to to
provide the Rob value and then um the
feature view is going to is going to
actually normalize it for you and that's
what that and app okay so one more thing
um that we basically taking this
specific U this specific Vector in this
case we actually creating a p data frame
out of it and then just call model that
predict and return the result we are
actually downloading either approv or
denied so if you actually click this
one it's actually um first request Tak a
little bit more time because you has to
set up things but anyway um in generally
speaking a couple of MCS you get back to
data provided you up the application um
and then you basically get back your
result from from this specific model
right again here you can basically just
you know keep changing your attributes
and play around with things and see what
the model predicts or not um gener
speaking if if you try at home then you
will see that the model is not it's not
great um approves all the loans probably
but uh yeah that's good anyway uh that
that wasn't the point of the
presentation but anyway
um so that's kind of where we are um one
thing I want I want to talk about is um
how do we avoid breaking things so I
have a couple more minutes there um if
you remember like every time I was
referring to a specific feature group
object or feature view object um I was
referring to with a specific version um
and the reason for that SEC yeah and the
reason for that is to be able to do um
either both CCD but also to do like
stage or lot of things right so we said
there earlier in let me just jump back
in the code we said earlier in the uh
when we we're creating the features is
that we don't want to necessarily like
work out of notebooks I mean they're
good for like exploration and building
PCS but then ultimately we want to make
sure that we are tracking changes we
want to make sure that we are testing
things um and that's where the feature
functions are coming into the picture
right so let's say for instance um I
want to um I want to drop one of the
features because it's a duplicate let's
say um what I would have to do in obor
is I would have I would have to create a
new version of that specific group right
so I would have to go here down here
into the um create feature group and
instead of having loans version one I
would have to create loans version two
right this we create a completely
independent version of my feature group
same name potential same description but
it's different different entity right
and so when I actually go and look at
where a specific oh this popped up no
okay um where a specific um feature
group is being used I can see that in
this case is used by the loan approval
version one so loan verion one uh Lo
feature group version one is is going to
keep being used in the loans loans
approval feature view version one um but
I can also go and say okay I want to
create version two I want to decate um
this specific version right so I want to
basically say every time someone is
going to try to use version one we
actually get a warning we actually
actually basically say hey there is a
newer version you might want to use it
um so I can keep running can keep having
the pipeline running in the background
here uh for um all the Modas the C lion
version version one and I can slowly
like retrain all the Modas to be able to
use the version two of the feature group
that I created and same thing happens in
the same thing happens in the feature
view level um what you can see here um
up here can basically say okay here we
using specific version version one of
the feuture uh group loans and
applicants um and we are creating
version one as well of
the here actually um version one of the
um of the feature view object right um
if you were to select different features
um if you were to apply let's say
different transformation functions or or
like add different filters for instance
then you basically will have to U
increment the version of the of the
feature view
itself um and then ultimately you know
what that's that's exactly the what you
need to remember in your training
pipeline you basically have to say Okay
I'm going to use version one or version
two of my feature view which ultimately
going to be using version one or two of
the um feature group objects underneath
essentially right so everything is
versioned um and you basically have um a
way to um basically have like a big red
button to basically say okay new version
doesn't work um let let's roll back to
the previous version uh of of off oh
sorry of um of
Vis um and you can do the same um we hav
we haven't really touched upon on this
specific case we can do the same at the
model level um here if you're using the
the service platform you can actually
deploy models um beond like a rest in
point um we use a tool called K serve to
power that that's um um the model
serving framework that comes out of C
flow um and so um us some of the
kubernetes tools like ISO and so on to
be able to do like Network traffic
traffic um and you can basically say
Okay um you maybe initially you can have
okay this doesn't make 100 sense but
anyway let me see okay there's there's
some math error in the slide you
basically say 90% go into the um into
the first one and then 10% go into the
second one right or actually okay now
that makes sense um you send 10% of the
traffic to both actually to the both the
BL model um and degree model essentially
so that you can actually monitor how the
existing how the existing predictions
are are are are doing
essentially and that's what we talk
about is and that's everything I have
for you um I have 10 more minutes I
think
actually 240 240 okay but there a break
oh yeah yeah is a break
until okay yeah so if you have any
questions or like anything like this um
just let me know otherwise you can find
me and bunch of my colleagues um in on
SL so if you want to try out a tutorial
at home or um to any point then
yeah that's
it can get um they are here um in
SL tutorials actually let me put back
this one so you can take a picture of it
let see I
here yeah
yeah it's yeah yeah there are L to uh
this one here loan
approval so then you have uh 01 to
three and I think this should be uh
should be a requirements fight as well
yes um but the requirements are just
installing Ops and installing radio or
second as well yeah
do you have any mechanis to detect
dfta um not right now that's something
we're building in the background um
that's the that's what I was mentioning
in terms of like um like but the data
actually meet certain expectations and
and you know either write it or not uh
into the into the feature groups um and
then the other aspect that that's
something that we that we are building
right now um is the data validation
aspect where you basically say uh look
at the um look at the statistics of a
specific to asset right um so yeah okay
these are now deated let me undate
them
um this um you can look at basically the
statistics of a specific train the asset
um and then you can compare them with
the new statistics that you compute
every time um data comes in in the
physic group so one thing that you do um
I didn't mention I just show really
quickly was that when you create new um
when you create when you inest new data
you actually see that in the in the UI
you can actually see um activity that
happen in terms of like new roles that
have been injested roles that have been
updated based on the primary key um and
rows have been deleted um you can see
like different metata operations like in
this cas case we updated the
expectations rate um and what you can
actually see is actually different
statistics as well so every time you
create new new values um sorry every
time you you write new data we take a
new snapshot of the statistics that we
can that we can compare
essentially yeah but that's that's
something that that is going to come up
soon yeah okay and in feature group you
store the row feature you the
information about processing that was
applied to the fature um for some
information yes uh depending a little
bit on how you depending a little bit on
how you you're structuring if you're
doing theen VI in offs then we can
detect the code and we can actually
store it in OB um in like in this case
it on on my own laptop um you will you
can actually attach the like the commit
ID that you can actually have that you
actually have for the specific um for
that specific um for that specific data
commit essenti that you have here so I
can compute the op as well yeah you can
compute in op as well yes or you can do
as side so if you are um you know if you
if you already have like a spark cluster
for instance you already have a flame
cluster or a python engine somewhere you
can actually you can actually use it and
connect your outside cluster to to right
into could could you pleas show the
model reg
yeah yeah so this is the model that I I
register earlier um um so this is the
The Landing model um you can have
multiple version for the models as well
um you you can actually do a couple
different things let me see actually
here let see if I register the example
well this is a simple example where you
basically say um this is B the metata
that you have attached to it um this is
the schema that the model expects um
this is what comes out of the feature
view object essentially um so different
different features and different type of
features that that we expect um what you
can actually do is you can actually
deploy this specific version so you can
actually um spin up one or more docket
containers in the background um using
Cas Ser as was mentioning um to be able
to create a new deployment um and be
able to have an endpoint to be able to
sell that if you do that then you can
actually um you can actually um how do
you say uh you can actually make request
to it um either through the UI or
through the API to be able to actually
send send a request to it can I compare
different ml
experiments um not necessarily
experiments unless you
models right if you register if you if
you register the output of the
experiment model and you attach the The
Matrix that you have here so if you look
at uh this one here um here you can
basically see well we have one version
of the model um so that's kind of the
vales the met that weach if you were to
have multiple version you and also
potentially multiple Matrix you would
basically have all the Matrix for all
the versions sorry yes all the values
for all the Matrix for all the versions
essentially
okay and can I check the feure
importance um not like not out of the
box like you would have to do it you
have to do it yourself
essentially yeah um is there a way
to like
cons have like clients are the users of
models yeah um will be like implenting
the
API results in real time but then we
manage the
model I think I think it depends on the
deployment so this is like this is the
deploy this is the deployment we have
appear for the community to use then
there's a ob also a company behind it um
um and we have a booth tomorrow um we
can actually I can actually show you the
um like the Enterprise version of it so
you can have a look at this and that you
can deploy it within your own PPC on
your own cloud or even on Prem if you're
on Prem um and then you can actually
manage the depending a little bit on
what you are if you're on PR you also
have to manage the infrastructure um but
you can definitely manage the the entire
process to creating the features
building the features deploying the
model and then exposing the uh the end
point to to the to the to your
customers
so yeah yeah if you're if you're curious
about it then and uh we can actually
yeah we can you can I think we are
upstairs tomorrow I think
something um yeah yeah based on what you
just mentioned so um is there a way for
you to uh like choose what which back
hand you want to use for either the
offline store and the online store like
if I want to go with a Reddit or Dynamo
something um yes and no um you can use
you can use so forline feat store no um
the store is our own inmemory um
database uh that's called on to be um
the reason it's stct is because it's
better performance and has a lot of
nicer features we can scale it up and
down is that proprietory uh no it's um
it's actually gpl2 or something like
this right um the offline storage we are
a little bit more flexible um we can
create um what we call um external F
groups where you basically you can
basically say this specific you can
basically tell OB this specific Vis
group is actually this SQ qu running on
this data
right and then yeah we have actually
connectors here available so then you
can basically I don't know configure
either B snowflake right Shi um you can
have um you know data legs like S3 um
GCS and there should be also ADLs
somewhere um but basically can I
basically have a flexibility on that to
basically say this specific group is
actually my own data and that's um
that's nice because you know often times
you already have those Pips in place
right and you just want to lever in them
um into obss um and data if you use
external F groups so you mount them from
outside the data stays outside so we
don't bring into obook the only reason
we need to bring it into up is if you
want to use the online Feet store so
that point we have to take it from let's
say snowflake and get it into the online
feature store for doing real time and
and so based on what you're mentioning I
assume that the online feature store run
in your infrastructure there's no way
you
like yeah it depends and okay in this
case everything El nor infrastructure
but like it if you're deploying within
your own VPC then also the online F can
can can decide on on on your own
infrastructure side um so you have
control over that as well um we have
again if if you show up tomorrow at boo
then I can show you a little bit detail
the the control plane to basically scale
it up and down and upgrade it and stuff
like this cool
thanks but more questions yeah how much
time to uh the online feature ingestion
um yeah so we have some benchmarks uh
that are available I think we are
depending a little bit on the on the PIP
so there are two aspects there right the
first aspect is the pipeline itself
that's usually the most um intense part
like if you're doing IND streaming
application appications that's usually
where most of the time is spent and then
we have some over right to get the data
from let's say your like spark steaming
application or P application into the
feat store and then you're talking like
sub cycle to to be able to get it there
um in terms of retrieving it from the
online feature store um we have some
benchmarks available and they are like
we are talking single digit micycle data
once the data is already on the onl
feore there was a question in the back
yeah is there a way to see how the
prediction values are being calculated
and canet those sorry is there a way to
see how your prediction values are
calculated my prediction value in the
model or yeah um you they are basically
they're basically just out of this one
I'm seeing
uh what is the yes
no um it's just a metc you compute it's
just dictionary that you provide in the
specific um the specific value here so
you're basically the curacy here that up
here
somewhere here so you basically Define
whatever method you want and just
basically provide dictionary with metric
and specific value it's not something
that like the the moderat that's for you
okay yeah yeah thank you very
much